sí
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález el
presidente de brasil ya ha ido bolsonaro
está nuevamente contra la pared de por
su negacionismo de la pandemia del cob y
19 ahora tal parece que le está
comenzando a pasar factura después de
seis meses de investigaciones la
comisión del senado que estaba
precisamente investigando el desempeño
del mandatario en su manejo de la
pandemia del cob y 19 presentó su
informe final la comisión indicó haber
encontrado gravísimas irregularidades
que llevaron a sugerir que el mandatario
debería ser imputado por crímenes contra
la humanidad y ocho delitos más
el documento fue aprobado por siete
votos a favor y cuatro en contra tras
esta aprobación fue remitido a la
justicia ordinaria también a la fiscalía
a la corte suprema y hasta la corte
penal internacional no sólo contra el
presidente por sonar o hay algunas
acusaciones sino contra otras 78
personas y dos empresas el presidente de
los brasileños es acusado de nueve
delitos todos tipificados en el código
de brasil como por ejemplo infracciones
de medidas sanitarias charlatanería
médica incitación al delito epidemia con
resultado de muerte falsificación de
documentos uso irregular de dinero
público prevaricato y atentado contra la
dignidad del cargo qué opciones tiene el
presidente bolsonaro que trámite puede
tener esto en la justicia brasileña qué
futuro tendrá el mandatario quien ha
calificado toda esta investigación como
una gran payasada y ha desestimado este
trámite que pueda tener en la justicia
brasileña porque se llegó hasta esta
instancia la situación política de
brasil y las acusaciones contra el
presidente de yair bolsonaro son nuestro
tema de debate hoy en france 24 para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
eugenio around él es abogado del partido
de los trabajadores ex ministro de
justicia en el mandato de dilma rousseff
se encuentra en la ciudad de brasilia la
capital federal también está con
nosotros aitor freire él es diputado
federal por el partido social liberal
también se encuentra en la ciudad de
brasilia la capital del país y aquí en
el estudio de france 24 se encuentra con
julio césar gómez dos santos ya político
brasileño egresado de la academia
diplomática de brasil ustedes también
nuestros televidentes pueden ser parte
de este debate a través de sus
comentarios y preguntas en nuestras
redes sociales estamos en facebook en
instagram y en twitter síganos como
france24
arroba xanthi lobo les recuerdo que
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios y
preguntas sobre este tema que tiene que
ver con este país suramericano pues
quiero comenzar con nuestros invitados
en la ciudad de brasilia que ya estamos
conectados con ellos para comenzar a
armar este rompecabezas ya entender y
hacer análisis de la situación que se
está viviendo allí comienzo con el genio
aragáo en brasilia y que curso puede
tener este informe esta acusación para
que llegue a una instancia legal que
otros trámites tienen que seguir hasta
llegar a una acusación formal contra el
presidente bolsonaro para entender un
poco la legislación brasileña para los
que estamos fuera de las fronteras de
este país bienvenido
una noche para mis más grandes hacer es
una grande satisfacción hablar con
ustedes bueno una comisión parlamentaria
de investigación
del querido que se llamen brasil es una
instancia política no el informe final
es un documento sobre todo político
evidentemente hay aspectos allí técnicos
de clasificación de los delitos por
ejemplo pero estas clasificaciones no
son vinculantes
significa que el ministerio público
cuando recibe este informe no está
obligado a
clasificar los hechos de hacer verlo con
la comisión no y de la misma forma
también cuando se lleva este este
documento a la policía federal es lo
mismo no entonces no hay que esperar que
seguramente van a
que van a
completamente el informe pero como
documento político tiene un gran impacto
claro seguramente y yo creo que este es
la principal importancia del consejo
aitor también en la ciudad de brasilia
esto podrá tener curso a nivel legal o
como dice eugenio tienes un curso más
político más que una acusación formal
contra el presidente
buena noche saludo a todo el trabajo de
ser humillado por la cpi fue mucho más
pirotécnico que investigativo y claro yo
creo que la cpi son instrumentos legales
de la liga de legítimos de la democracia
pero en este caso ellos fueron
utilizados de manera completamente
engañosa arrojando falacias a la sólida
sociedad como el del genocidio por
ejemplo
entonces es más una una
comisión de política que
qué ilegal y a una cuestión interna de
la justicia brasileña también no tiene
por qué fue en viena enviado a las
naciones unidas entonces todos estos
aspectos muestran que es más político
donde el mismo legal
y aquí en el estudio de france 24 julio
césar gómez los santos su opinión sobre
este rompecabezas tiene más curso a
nivel esto político que legal esto podrá
trascender allí en la justicia brasileña
como lo ve usted bueno nosotros los
buenas noches buenas noches
ministro buenas noches diputados
los dos eligieron lo que pensaban en el
lado legal y tampoco e incluso el
aspecto político se
evidentemente usted me perdone señor
diputado pero evidentemente que
engañosos también son los facebooks del
señor presidente de la república que
está siendo analizado en distintas
instancias
político y
ilegales brasil entonces yo yo puedo
incluso de una cierta forma estar de
acuerdo en que se diga que la cpi de
lakovic tiene un lado político muy muy
fuerte y esto faltando un año para las
elecciones
evidentemente que causa algún
para los analistas políticos
decidir en de qué lado el pueblo
brasileño el elector brasileño va a
estar en octubre del año que viene
yo pienso personalmente como brasileño
como el lector
que hubo un cambio muy grande
en brasil después de la elección de jair
bolsonaro pero no un cambio para mejor o
para peor en nuevas la vida de los
brasileños un cambio del comportamiento
del brasileño y en brasil nunca hubo una
polarización como existe hoy
y esto es malo para el país quién fue el
culpable de la polarización no podemos
decir exactamente ahora tenemos de un
lado la izquierda
representada por el partido de los
trabajadores señor luiz inácio lula da
silva y en la derecha por jair bolsonaro
esta polarización surgió a mi juicio por
el inicio de un proceso en mi país por
el cual a través del mismo presidente a
la república y de un grupo de sus
aliados en un llamado gabinete del odio
sí excepto bueno pues es que
precisamente el meollo de todo este
asunto es las elecciones que están a la
vuelta de la esquina ya prácticamente me
dicen que quiere pedir la palabra para
a opinar al respecto aitor adelante
si de esa foto desafortunadamente que la
cpi de la cob y fue mucho más un show
pirotécnico que investigativo creo que
impactará los resultados de las
electorales pero de manera negativa
ya que el trabajo se hizo la mitad y
muchas personas que deberían ser
investigadas no fueron como los alcaldes
y gobernadores
si hablamos del omisión o del dinero del
gobierno salió del gobierno federal pero
llegó a la pequeña ciudad en brasil pasó
por el los gobernadores y
escuchamos de casos que
respiradores por ejemplo a una ciudad
fue vendida a un determinado valor y la
ciudad al lado fue vendido de 10 veces
el valor a mano o sea que los alcaldes
los gobernadores
estas empresas que empresas que
recibieron el dinero no fueron
investigada por tanto la el trabajo de
la cpi de la comisión parlamentaria fue
por la mitad no fue algo
imparcial
fue más algo parcial seguí mirando las
elecciones
del próximo año porque era sin una un
efecto político
entonces
alcaldes gobernadores no fueran
investigados y juzgados por tanto yo
pienso que fue algo que la izquierda que
la oposición de brasil quería hacer un
poco antes de las elecciones tse eugenio
en su opinión sobre esto que dice héctor
que esto puede ser orquestado desde la
izquierda brasileña de cara a estas
elecciones presidenciales que tienen
lugar el año entrante qué opina esta vez
no yo no puedo concordar
la cpi en un
parlamento federal sólo puede investigar
autoridades federales las autoridades
estaduales y autoridades municipales
están sujetas a investigación por las
asambleas
estaduales por lo tanto no es una
cuestión
de escoger un algo es una cuestión de
encuadramiento constitucional
no y seguramente hay mucho así dicho
investigado sobre el gobierno federal
por su pésima gestión de la acogida en
la actitud
insistentemente
negacionista del presidente que salió en
las ciudades sin ningún tipo de
protección con un pésimo ejemplo para la
gente si no entonces
pero no es sólo esto hizo también
propaganda sistemática
del llamado kit hold it que es un
conjunto de medicaciones que son ya
probadas por los organismos
internacionales como ineficaces se para
el combate de la comida entonces yo creo
que fue lamentablemente una anarquía que
se instaló en el gobierno federal la
total incapacidad del presidente de
hacer una coordinación nacional para el
combate de la comida
los gobernadores y los alpes en alcaldes
tuvieron que asumir este papel sin
ningún tipo de coordinación y eugenio y
esto fue un desastre julio aquí en el
estudio de france 24
eugenio habla de esta coordinación que
no hubo entre el gobierno federal y los
gobernadores de los estados para
coordinar una estrategia pero tal parece
y según lo dicen algunos medios
brasileños
la estrategia del mandatario era llegar
a una a un contagio masivo para que la
enfermedad simplemente desapareciera a
través de la inmunidad de rebaño tal vez
no hubo comunicación de eso no hubo de
verdad un entendimiento por parte de
autoridades federales estados ciudades
ciudadanos o simplemente la estrategia
el presidente no le funcionó o no había
estrategia
en primer lugar es muy interesante muy
importante dejar claro que brasil es una
federación no es un estado unitario como
es colombia
entonces los gobernadores tienen una
cierta
autonomía libertad para hacer las cosas
que le quedan a sus jóvenes eeuu está
pasando lo mismo ahí estado seguir los
gobernadores quieren una cosas y otros
no entonces lo que pasa es lo que dijo
el ministro
es muy es muy correcto y si hubo una en
portugués aún avanza en por parte del
gobierno federal y si no hubo una un
intento siquiera por cubos y reuniones
con los gobernadores en brasilea puesto
para una política unificada que fuera
atrayente a todos los gobernadores de
partidos políticos distintos porque lo
que se estaba discutiendo en ese momento
no era política era la seguridad
nacional era la salud del pueblo
brasileño y este señor que quería que
existía que la la las vacunas y todo
esto eran una tontería que salía a
abrazar la gente la calle sino un pata
para bocas este señor trató de encontrar
la solución en una
con productos médicos que ya no eran
aprobados por nadie un kit combi y cosas
por el estilo s esto fue absolutamente
inaceptable para la población y yo
pienso que él tiene que responder por
esto
aitor qué piensa usted sobre este
supuesto plan que había de inmunidad vía
contagio para que los brasileños
simplemente padecieron la enfermedad
hubiera allí en este país una inmunidad
de rebaño y no a tener que hacer uso de
las vacunas que es lo que ha generado
tanta controversia con la decisión del
presidente y lo que en realidad de
pronto el pueblo brasileño necesitaba en
ese momento
yo me vacuné y digo siempre para todos
que se vacunen también
personalmente yo creo en la ciencia y en
los avances medical es en este periodo
de pandemia entonces no hay defensa
cuanto a estas cuestiones
no no estoy aquí para hacer una defensa
del presidente porque no concordó con
estas afirmaciones que
solamente en la ritmos
la inmunización del rebaño
tenemos la ciencia y para auxiliar la
humanidad tenemos profesionales pero en
el en el inicio cuando empezó la
pandemia estábamos todo el mundo los
grandes países como estados unidos
inglaterra
china y nadie sabía conocía las vacunas
o no tendría estudios
comprendo que en el cuando empezó en el
inicio cuando empezó la pandemia
estábamos todos queriendo
encontrar algo que salva a hacer vidas
entonces eran cuando empezó tal vez
cualquier cosa o vitamina c 5 que salva
seis vidas es sería aceptable pero
porque el mundo la ciencia no tendría
una vacuna clara pero después después de
tenemos la vacuna después de conocíamos
la pandemia y lo que les olvida mira
ahora que la muerte prácticamente
desaparecer en brasil por qué porque
tenemos una gran cantidad de personas
vacunadas de ya entonces tal vez sería
aceptable en net cuando empezó la
pandemia pero después hater el gobierno
federal todos debería incentivar la
vacuna 6
paso a preguntarle a eugenio retomamos
la conexión con él en la ciudad de
brasilia llama la atención que este
documento que han presentado allí en
brasil le pide a los tribunales que el
presidente sea suspendido por un tiempo
de las redes sociales él es muy activo
en las redes sociales difunde su opinión
y da y hace comentarios y habla de su
día a día como presidente de los
brasileños pero hay ciertos sectores que
califican esto como censura como lo ve
usted
mira yo creo que
sacar el presidente de las redes
sociales de una forma general yo creo
que tal vez
bueno se ha congelado la señal con
eugenio pasó a ser la entonces la
pregunta a mi invitado en el estudio a
julio césar se quitó se está llevando
esto aún a los límites de la censura a
sacar al presidente quitarle la
posibilidad de expresar libremente a
través de las redes sociales este 1 de
acuerdo o no con lo que él expresa a
través de sus cuentas
judicialmente podría parecer una especie
de censura pero no hay necesidad de
hacerlo porque anteayer
youtube y facebook lo sacaron y lo
censuraron
porque molesto no a los brasileños
molesto al mundo en el momento en que
dijo que la vacuna podría llevar al sida
y eso es una cosa inaceptable es decir
decir que la comisión de investigación
del senado
sobre el asunto de kobe
es una exageración y un engaño cuando el
más grande engaño está dentro del
palacio gubernamental
del señor presidente de la república con
sus fake news y con su gabinete del odio
él fue censurado por youtube y por
facebook por 8 días bueno retomó la
conexión con eugenia en brasilia su
opinión nos estaba hablando de si esto
es una censura ya tenemos aquí la
opinión de julio césar que nos dice que
que pues él prácticamente se censuró con
su comentario y las mismas empresas
tuvieron que retirar sus cuentas y
congelar
la cuenta y la actividad no tuvieron que
hacer nada las autoridades brasileñas
qué opina usted
bueno yo creo que
una censura puntual creo que es más que
suficiente yo creo que no es adecuado
sacarlo completamente de las redes
sociales
pero seguramente lo que hizo ahora
facebook y también youtube por lo
correcto
fue una señal para el presidente que no
pueda hablar lo que quiere contra la
ciencia y contra
toda una política necesaria para
contenerla cubit
diciendo por ejemplo que
vacunas podrían transmitir la ácida esta
es una locura no entonces yo creo sí que
fue correcto
este tipo de suspensión pero yo no soy
favor de una que se saque por completo
yo creo que esto significa esto sólo
serviría para victimizar el presidente
no hay necesidad y entre pero toda vez
que va a hablar algo que realmente es
contra el interés público sí yo creo que
debe ser sus pintas suspendido héctor y
sobre este tema su opinión se puede
censurar o no al presidente y le amplió
la pregunta
los brasileños creen este tipo de
comentarios que hace el presidente a
través de las redes sociales este tipo
de comentarios que no tienen ningún
sustento científico que lo hemos visto a
lo largo de todos estos años que dice
cualquier cantidad de cosas
yo soy de la base del gobierno en la
cámara de los diputados
pero afirmó para todos que están
escuchando no es el tiempo de comentario
que creemos esto no es verdad yo no creo
esto y me siento con vergüenza me
disculpen la sinceridad
que la vacuna tomamos vacunas desde
chicos en brasil tenemos un sistema un
sistema de salud que es muy bueno en
nuestro sur y la cantidad de personas
que sean salvados con vacunas en brasil
es muy grande entonces no creemos en
este tipo de comentarios fue
tal vez un comentario o infortunio del
presidente yo soy un gran defensor de la
libertad entonces no importa si es
no importa si es de la izquierda o de la
derecha 2 yo soy un defensor de la
libertad
el presidente tiene sus seguidores tiene
personas que acreditan en él tal vez no
concordia 100% pero
lo sé quien él fue electo
democráticamente
entonces es sacar el de los medios
sociales nuestra mente no es algo
saludable para la democracia brasileña
julio césar a ustedes diplomático ha
vivido muchos años por fuera de brasil
este tipo de situaciones a las que se
está enfrentando el gobierno brasileño
el presidente
estas posibles acusaciones a nivel
judicial como afectan la imagen del país
el mismo presidente ya lo decía hoy en
algunos medios de comunicación que toda
esta investigación era una payasada pero
que esto a nivel internacional si le
cobraba una factura muy grande a brasil
evidentemente evidentemente que esto no
es bueno para nuestra política exterior
no es bueno para la imagen de brasil
nosotros siempre tuvimos una política
exterior de estado nunca de partido y
tratamos de seguir así porque
la diplomacia brasileña es 100%
profesional no tenemos políticos en
ningún rango en ninguna embajada
y eso ahora nos está afectando
anímicamente a los diplomáticos yo no
estoy más en la carrera porque estoy
jubilado pero todos mis colegas mis
amigos están sintiendo esta presión que
nunca habíamos sentido ni siquiera
durante régimen militar además hay que
decir unas cosas la política exterior
brasileña
independiente y responsable fue creación
de un general de la dictadura
el general guy selz este hombre en
1975 cambió totalmente
la política
de los militares hasta entonces de a
casi alineamiento con estados unidos se
para hacer una política independiente y
responsable que este señor que fue
militar y que advocaat la dictadura y
todo lo que pasó durante 21 años en
brasil tenía 9 años de edad cuando el
golpe militar nueve años no tuvo
conocimiento de esto
hasta grande
y ahora hace una política exterior
contraria a esta que nosotros estamos
acostumbrados desde el general guy set
en
1975 claro y le pregunto a eugenio en la
ciudad de brasilia que le cobra más
factura a un país como brasil una
potencia económica en la región
suramericana los comentarios
desacertados del presidente o este tipo
de investigaciones que muestran una
institucionalidad de una división de
poderes y que el presidente desacredita
él mismo está criticando las mismas
instituciones
mira en cuanto a las instituciones
funcionan brasil se muestra un país
serio un país que puede ser ser
reconocido como un partido con un par
cero
confiable no porque tiene instituciones
seguras yo creo que el papel que la cpi
hizo es un papel muy importante si
seguramente hay aquí y hay cola aún a
una política politización de los debates
esta es parte del parlamento pero el
trabajo fue muy importante porque puso
luz sobre muchos aspectos que no estaban
visibles para el público como por
ejemplo la de la compra de vacunas
indianas no por esquemas extremamente
de extremamente obscuros no que no tuvo
lugar al final pero podría tenido
lugares sería seguramente una forma de
corrupción muy grave entonces
fueron muchos hechos importantísimos que
fueron fueron puesto de forma
transparente por la cpi yo creo que esto
es muy importante para informar
la población en brasil y también para
demostrar internacionalmente que
nosotros somos un país serio que estamos
investigando los hechos
y entonces al mismo tiempo yo tengo
muchas reservas en por ejemplo llevar
estos hechos para que instancias
internacionales penales esto es una otra
cuestión no sé por ejemplo el tribunal
penal internacional yo no creo que el
tribunal penal internacional fue creado
para esto no pero a ella ángel sea
cierta discusión
claro ya llegamos a la recta final del
programa quiero hacer las conclusiones
que cada uno de ustedes diga que piensa
que pueda suceder en todo este caso el
presidente se enfrentará a la justicia
esto afectará las elecciones
puntualmente como las puede afectar como
lo ven ustedes nos quedan muy pocos
minutos por favor sean muy puntuales
comienzo con héctor para hacer este
cierre del programa
y como ha dicho en durante el programa
el trabajo desempeñado por la cpi fue
mucho más pirotécnico político que
investigativo estoy seguro que la cpi es
un instrumento legítimo de la democracia
pero en este caso fueron utilizados de
manera completamente engañosa entonces
no quiero hacer una defensa del
presidente pero entiendo que si el
presidente lee si le imputen este este
delito defiendo que también están
imputados todos los alcaldes de
gobernadores investigados por la policía
federal está al trabajar de la cpi fue
un fracaso y que no se ha completado
entonces fue algo parcial
el político mirando las elecciones en el
próximo 11 aquí en el estudio julio su
conclusión sobre lo que puede suceder en
brasil en los próximos meses con este
caso yo no pienso que legalmente haya
tiempo suficiente para que las
acusaciones al presidente de la
república pueden ser analizadas y
juzgadas durante su gobierno lo que
quiere su gobierno políticamente como
dice el diputado hizo un
ramas como no es el la gente que lo
sigue los pocos que lo siguen los 20 por
ciento lo seguirán porque sus cielos si
ahora en mi país donde el voto es
obligatorio
no es como en colombia o en estados
unidos o en europa en mi país es
obligatorio en octubre del año que viene
tendremos la respuesta a su pregunta
bueno y eugenio para el cierre del
programa en la ciudad de brasilia en la
capital que viene para este país no hay
bola de cristal no sabemos el futuro
pero que puede suceder
bueno yo creo que el próximo año va a
ser un año de fuertes emociones no yo no
creo que está aquí este
el relatorio de la cpi pueda tener
prontamente respuestas judiciales
seguramente van a empezar a investigar
pero lo que va a ocurrir es muy cierto
difícil pero seguramente hay un impacto
hay una discusión y la discusión solo
sobre la mala gestión de la vid va a
hacer parte de la campaña presidencial
además que el año entrante pues vamos a
seguir todavía en la capa en la pandemia
de kobe 19 porque esto no ha terminado
no sabemos cuándo va a terminar entonces
sin duda alguna si esto se prolonga pues
será un tema obligado en los temas
sanitarios en esa campaña presidencial
en el año que viene pues a mis tres
invitados del día de hoy les agradezco
por haber compartido con nosotros sus
opiniones en torno a este tema un
rompecabezas complicado y armar sobre la
política brasileña pero que queríamos
traer y explicarle a nuestra audiencia
en américa latina' a los tres muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
también a la audiencia de france 24
gracias sigan dejando sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales sigan en sintonía con
buenas noches
[Música]